he hates paying his own rent and he is
chronically poor Kelly Ripa is all about
that tough love when it comes to her
kids we are I would say stricter than
most of the parents the 49 year old
stopped by Jimmy Kimmel on Tuesday and
revealed that her 22 year old son
Michael who recently graduated from NYU
is living in Brooklyn and let's just say
he isn't exactly living a life of
leisure I think he loves the freedom
mm-hmm he hates paying his own rent and
he is chronically poor mm-hmm I don't
think he ever really experienced you
know extreme poverty you know like now
things are apparently so bleak that
Michael even looks forward to receiving
those holiday cards stuffed with $20
cash from his grandparents but now these
living on his own he's called like three
times in via Halloween envelope variety
so we can have past electricity he's
experiencing being an adult
Kelly admitted that she wasn't all that
jazzed when Michael decided to go to
school in the same city he grew up in I
said well then you're gonna be like
other kids and come home when it's
regular visiting hours like Thanksgiving
Christmas that's it
I'm here John and I need to rediscover
each other yeah well things didn't quite
go as kelly had planned we drop him off
freshman year drop them off at his dorm
we have lunch together we look at each
other we say we did it we have a child
in college we did it
oh my gosh we come home it's about ten
minutes away we come home walk through
the front door he is standing in the
hallway
now the daytime talk-show host and her
hubby Mark Consuelos says 18 year old
daughter is studying at NYU she's
following in big brother's footsteps so
what advice have you given both of them
as they kind of make their own way their
peers that they're going to school with
are people that they're going to be
working with so make connections
cultivate those relationships they're
also they're both very dear friends are
in both different disciplines and
they're both very different types of
people but I think what they have
learned
so far in their young lives is that you
show up for people when they show up for
you while Lola was a little more amped
on the idea of leaving home she wasn't
ready to leave behind all the perks
truck rough on a Saturday Sunday evening
are alarmed trips my daughter's having a
party on the roof of our house
she was gone 12 hours yeah so after
having two kids attend NYU Kelly has one
rule for her sixteen-year-old son
Joaquin he's not allowed to even apply
to any white within the tri-state area
he caught up with Kelly and Mark in June
and they got candid about how they plan
to spend their time when they're empty
nesters Lola just graduated so you two
are closer to an espy know somebody's
close we are truly this close we we're
done two one I'm truly going to be
running through the house naked I just
want everybody to know I'm gonna be
sitting on every piece of furniture
naked the morning before you come over
that's what I'll be doing in my spirit
it's amazing and you're welcome America
well there's that do you Kelly
of course et will be here to keep you up
on all things mark and Kelly so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now
[Music]